comment voudriez-vous mourir pirate suspendu
embaucher pour votre invention la guillotine
guillotine ce français j'aime les français
saviez-vous que ça n'avait pas été ce soir à
quel point ça pouvait être c'est français hé
oh bébé ah voici une idée
Oh c'était mon bon vieux  façonné debout
j'ai tué mr.  pas maintenant impliquer la
foule n'est-ce pas
je voudrais parler de la victoire de
la montagne pensez à moi probablement pouvoir
je ne suis pas un peut jouer normalement mais ce
paniers pour la tête
[Musique] les
pirates avaient infecté les mers pendant des
générations
[  Musique]
comme nommé pensif mo et puis
il y avait ce garçon
juste salle de bain d'
accord mec
ils m'ont tout pris
complètement
atteindre
j'ai entendu l'histoire
du puissant capitaine espagnol avec son fils
à tuer des milliers d'hommes non non non les hommes
vont pirates
j'ai lu tous les ricanements Spanier  faire quelque chose
en espagnol
devenir une future personne expédier l'équipage
du passé Jack Lew Je suis tellement désolé que nous
parlions encore il n'y a pas de mots
baise légère pourquoi me référer à
partir de ce moment m'a appelé dans l'autre
sens tout ce temps est si où le
plus pas
[Musique]
arrête le singe
ne demande pas d'ennuis horrible blanc
Nalini
[Musique]
pour payer ce que tu m'as fait Les
mennonites cherchent une veste je
vais nager pour ça Karina arrête ça non
non non non ça va  est allé assez loin
non il a éteint j'ai vu ses chevilles vous venez de
voir beaucoup plus alors que vous gardiez votre
gâteau vous a tiré dessus